martin nolet a reçu un appel de guy
turcotte le 9 février 2009
il était alors agent immobilier les deux
hommes se connaissaient parce qu'ils
avaient des voisins par le passé guy
turcotte l'avait mandaté pour trouver
une maison dans le secteur de prévost le
témoin a affirmé que l'ex cardiologue
lui avait confié qu'il vivait une
séparation douloureuse et qu'il était en
colère contre son ex conjointe isabelle
gaston
six jours plus tard une offre d'achat
est acceptée et les deux hommes devaient
être présents pour l'inspection de la
propriété le samedi 21 février la veille
de l'inspection martin nolet a reçu un
message vocal de guy turcotte soit
quelques heures avant la découverte des
corps des emplois
nathalie le mel est une ancienne
collègue de travail de guy turcotte a
aussi reçu un message vocal de l'accusé
une semaine après le drame ce message a
été laissé dans sa boîte vocale au
travail
l'accusé mentionne aussi qu'il a besoin
d'argent notre entretien
jamais passé plein et les démarches à
nouveau trois entretiens dans son
message
guy turcotte qui a également remercié
plusieurs de ses collègues notamment des
cardiologues avec qui il travaillait
pour jour que malgré beaucoup pour
former plus bas le procès suspendu
jusqu'à mardi la couronne a fait
entendre jusqu'à présent dix neuf
témoins ici karen bastien radio canada
saint-girons